y las masacres que se han registrado en
la zona comparten características es
decir sabemos que la región concentra el
mayor número de cultivos de coca y que
grupos delincuenciales no sólo controlan
el negocio de la droga sino también de
los pasos ilegales en la frontera
si aquí lo que se está presentando es
una lucha que se ha dado no solamente en
el catatumbo en la zona frontera con
venezuela sino a diferentes partes del
país especialmente en temas de
narcotráfico
microtráfico y esta lucha que se
presenta con diferentes grupos armados
en este caso en cúcuta pues soy un grupo
que entra y sale por la frontera
venezuela teniendo en cuenta la ausencia
de una presencia integral del estado
pues puede cometer este tipo de
atrocidades como esta masacre que se
cometió el día de ayer y haciendo la
número 70 en lo que va corrido del año
se van diez masacres desde la desde que
entra el presidente gustavo petro que
está en la presidencia entonces pues es
muy preocupante la situación que se
tiene en estos momentos por la presencia
de estos grupos armados que lo que hacen
es prestar servicios de seguridad
narcotráfico
controlar el microtráfico también y
tener otro tipo de rentas de rentas de
la guerra como la corrupción cómo se
aprovechan entre otras cosas de las
empresas que hay ahí presentes y también
por supuesto de la minería bueno usted
lo estaba mencionando en un punto según
la policía colombiana en los primeros
siete meses de este año 255 personas
fueron asesinadas en la zona limítrofe
pero entonces qué pasa con el papel de
la policía y del estado en la zona
aquí hay una ausencia del estado en
general
especialmente lo que estamos nosotros
diciendo es que tiene que existir una
caracterización del conflicto no
solamente una presencia del estado de
una forma militar de una forma de
policía sino una caracterización de todo
lo que está sucediendo y esto significa
pues tener en cuenta las diversas
economías que hay tanto de las legales
como las ilegales tener en cuenta que
existe en esta zona una presencia de
palmas una presencia de de carbón
presencia de cultivos de uso ilícito hay
más de cuatro grupos armados que hacen
presencia en todo el departamento en las
diferentes zonas entonces tener un
contexto mucho más amplio para así la
investigación tenerla pues no solamente
el caso a caso de lo que está sucediendo
sino una investigación con una
caracterización mucho más amplia hacia
allá se hacia hacia dónde debe ir y hoy
lo que se está haciendo que está
ocurriendo es que se tiene una
investigación y una presencia de los
grupos armados
y solamente por parte de posición e
investigación muy muy de caso acaso
entonces se tiene que analizar de
diferentes contextos que están
presentándose en el terreno de alguna
forma la normalización de las relaciones
entre colombia y venezuela podría
contribuir a mejorar la situación en
esta zona
esperamos que si esperamos que la
normalización de la situación
especialmente con el gobierno de maduro
pues se pueda tener una colaboración
mucho más estrecha en la búsqueda en la
investigación en la frontera siempre las
guerras y los conflictos en las
fronteras la frontera no existen las
fronteras pues son porosas y
especialmente en una zona como catatumbo
pero si se requiere de en especial en
estos momentos de una colaboración por
parte de la afc de investigación de
policía y demás para poder estar detrás
de estos grupos armados y que cumplan
con la ley